all right well you were able to come up
with a meal that can feed a family of
four of four for under 20
absolutely so the meal that we're
preparing today is actually going to be
a yogurt marinated chicken it's a
grilled chicken
and it also comes with a ton of
vegetables it has red onion it has
broccoli so i know health was a concern
also so there's a lot of healthy stuff
going on
and then it comes with a side salad of a
grilled romaine with cucumbers and more
red onion and avocado so something nice
and fresh and all of that
came to a grand total of
19.83 cents
you can go on our website at the
drewbramershow.com and get that exact
list i love that it's written out that's
super organized and i don't have to
remember stuff it gets me all nervous
okay so sherry and fam the first tip
that i have when you're really trying to
keep things more affordable the spice
rack is your friend so here we have all
these wonderful spices we have paprika
and cumin and turmeric and some chili
flake
and then we're also gonna use some
yogurt for the marinade but the second
tip is when you're developing recipes or
when you're thinking of cooking
something you want to use the
ingredients in multiple ways so that you
get like more bang for your buck so in
this recipe we're going to have it in
as a marinade and then it's going to
show up a little later as a dressing for
our salad and drew i know sometimes
people don't want to do chicken you can
also substitute for a really beautiful
cauliflower steak i will represent the
vegetarian the vegetarians equally
equally delicious we're gonna also grate
some garlic into this and then you know
me i love cilantro stems use the
cilantro stems for the marinade use the
leaves for the garnish and the salad
that way you're really maxim maximizing
all your ingredients
so we're going to mix that in
we're going to do a little bit of lemons
uh lime zest excuse me
as well and then we're going to loosen
it up with a little bit of olive oil and
then the last optional ingredient
i know you love this is a little bit of
hot sauce
so i'm awesome as soon as you get that
nice and mixed you're basically going to
where's my tongs you're going to
marinate the chicken in that and now we
have a very hot grill pan
to that marinade you're also putting the
vegetables right so we're going to put
i'm going to put the chicken down to
make more space for the vegetables
nice and simply
okay so i also added to the bowl the
marinated
broccoli and what about the onion
and the red onion as well absolutely
so that's all going down
this chicken filled marinade is going to
go it's starting to smell really good
right sherry's nodding over there i'm
gonna put this aside
and after you start grilling you're
basically gonna pop it in the oven so it
goes in the oven for at 425
for
about 15 to 20 minutes until the chicken
obviously or the cauliflower is fully
cooked through drew you okay
all right
you got this
teamwork
yes
be gone
all right
i'm helping you out over here
you usually do
you're the one who saves a little bit of
a hot pan all right thank you it looks
good it looked cooked okay so
that just came out of the oven in the
meanwhile we also have a grilled romaine
salad so i love grilled romaine i don't
know if you guys have ever had grilled
romaine it's one of my favorite things
to do
grill the lettuce a little bit because
that gives it a little sweetness a
little nuttiness but then the other
leaves the outer leaves remain crunchy
so it's just like a little update on
your romaine salad we have all this
fresh avocado cucumbers as well and then
the last thing we're going to do
actually
is make
the dressing so the other half of the
yogurt that we used earlier gets saved
for the dressing
and this is just
yogurt a little water to thin it out and
to stretch the ingredients really yogurt
with water just a little bit and then
the cilantro leaves from the cilantro
stems earlier and i'm gonna
plate it a little
i put the sauce on top yes so you're
gonna put your cauliflower on your plate
all right i would love for you guys to
start serving yourselves as well
um well this is all about you
you wouldn't know it with my shenanigans
but it is
um this looks beautiful is anyone going
for the cauliflower are you all doing
the chicken i'm trying some of the
cauliflower oh good um i am going to
join you in drying the cauliflower okay
ready so you're going perfect sorry
okay
i'm going in smells so good
that's delicious
[Applause]
well and you and i like the spice and
the flavors forget that we're twins you
and i are twins i would love to be your
twin any day
um sherry
what do you think
i love it i love that the cauliflower
has flavor to it usually you think
cauliflower and it's like mush or her
you know flavorless but the the crust on
that is
crust is your friend so
go visit your spice cabinet start
reaching in there ladies what do you
think
this might make me like spicy food yes
[Music]